sang yang happy erupted on Friday
spouting ash three kilometers into the
sky no one is in danger in the immediate
vicinity of the volcano the last
inhabitants fled ssangyong island
decades ago but 1400 kilometers away in
Darwin Australia the volcanic ash is
causing slightly more disruption air
traffic authorities suspended almost all
flights to and from the city's airport
that ash has come out it's been moving
quite rapidly to the southeast it's been
carried across Central Australia that's
the main body of ash from the earlier
option however there's an ongoing
eruption at the volcano now which is
still producing ash affecting the Darwin
area stranded air passengers were taking
the plight interruption stoic Lee you
got to be flexible and safety does come
first we looked at the screen all the
monitors cancel complete shock kata will
stay positive and positive thinking will
get a sec Australian officials said the
latest ash plume was expected to linger
for at least 18 hours and back on
Sanyang Island the volcanic eruptions
are continuing